foreign
welcome everyone by the way
um right there are no plan to fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest fire exit the two fire
exits through the partition doors are
currently not in use due to ongoing
Works therefore the fire exits are
through the main doors of the hall or
the storeroom adjacent to the stage the
fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded please
switch off mobile phones or turn them to
silent toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
members of the public while you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to emphasize to you
that this should be done without
disruption to the meeting and can only
be done from a designated area in the
public seating can I please therefore
ask you to raise your hand clearly in
the air if you wish to take photographs
or film this evening
we're not recording but I'll record I'm
quite disappointed really but
okay thanks
um
members there is a need to use
microphones I'm not being greedy but I'm
told this is apparently what the sound
people want us to do
um so I've got two microphones but uh
um
there is a need to use microphones
during the meeting when I invite you to
speak please wait until there is a
microphone in front of you before
speaking as microphones are needed for
the hearing Loop and for the audio
recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak and will be unmuted by
officers for you please make sure that
the microphone is directly in front of
your mouth before speaking members
voting will be done on the show of hands
in line with the Constitution I will ask
for a show of hands for and then against
recommendations we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting
thank you very much and when I get the
sign that we will formally start the
meeting
good evening everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the executive committee
on this day Thursday the 19th of January
2023.
I think everyone is here so in terms of
item one uh no need for apologies for
absence as we have a full attendance
non-members attending and I look to my
right councilor Hawaii councilor Eaves
um councilor Jill Waite and councilor
cross welcome this evening
and also our one member of the public
sitting over on the other side of the uh
of the of the room
um minutes of the meeting held on the
6th of December
2022 members they're in the agenda pack
hopefully you've had an opportunity to
read them first of all on points of
accuracy
yep
agreed
thank you
right item four to receive Declarations
of Interest any Declarations of interest
from the items on the agenda
nope okay Matt has referred to the
executive and I beg your pardon item
five questions on notice from counselors
and I see that we've got three questions
on notice
and I think we will turn
in order of those questions first of all
to council across
foreign
just before you start
um I see on 1.2 of the question pack
you've actually addressed your question
to the portfolio holder for strategic
planning and assets at councilor Ward
and yet the subject that you then go on
to talk about Falls actually within the
portfolio of Council of Mrs Belton
um I saw that councilor Belton was was
responsible for this but
Council award is I believe the portfolio
holder in charge of assets
and the funding is is to be directed
towards or including some of our assets
uh for example Mill Hall
we're talking about items on the agenda
um there's three items on the agenda
tonight and all the items actually have
the questions or notice have to actually
relate to the item rather than you
attempting to divert it to a specific
the item on the agenda that I'm
addressing is is funding uh and where
the funding for the from the UK SPF
um goes in particular the E4 section
which is allocated 600 000 pounds which
can be spent on the development
restoration or refurbishment of local
natural cult cultural and Heritage
assets and sites because the Heritage
assets and sites which would include
Mill Hall so I'm asking uh councilor
Ward whether
um any funding is to be specifically
directed towards
um Council across your question is
actually written here it makes no
reference to the Mill Hall it does quite
correctly uh relate to item seven so as
chairman I am going to redirect your
question and ask councilor Belton uh to
deal with it fair enough outside because
it's a general uh notice you're more
than welcome to sit down please don't
don't stand on ceremony right shall I
read the question then to councilor
Belton yeah thank you apologies for uh
the um misdirection of my question
um so the question is uh the council
prioritize the interventions in its
investment plan with sixty percent on e4
enhancing existing cultural historic and
Heritage institutions the investment
plan did not need to specify individual
Projects please provide specific
projects that are earmarked for these
funds
thank you Council across councilor
Belton
thank you thank you Council across
um
firstly so the report and the the motion
this evening or the recommendation this
evening specifically refers to the
funding for year one
um which is a very small amount of the
money and we only have a matter of weeks
to spend it um which is unhelpful
um but I'll go through and answer the
question so a set out in the report in
light of the limited time available to
deliver projects in this financial year
the council was intending to procure
goods and services directly and we're
currently exploring Options under
intervention E4 around commissioning
Community Arts and Cultural projects in
preparation for the coronation of King
Charles funding cultural events and
exhibitions improving the district's
tourism brand and promoting its cultural
offering as well as providing
opportunities for local culture or
Heritage institutions to access small
amounts of funding for projects in
advance of any Fuller grant program in
future years
at this stage it's not clear whether
funding can be rolled over and therefore
it we are identifying projects that can
be delivered in the short space of time
that we have under the year one funding
at this point projects for years two and
three which is where the substantial
money comes forward have not yet been
been determined the council welcomes
suggestion from members and stakeholders
such as parish councils and Community
groups and there will be an opportunity
to distribute funding through a grant
program as well as directly procured
services
foreign
cross do you have a supplementary
um yes
it was really to establish whether the
Mill Hall and Castle Hall in particular
were to be considered uh in future years
for investment it had been sent said to
me by the counselor that I was going to
address the questions to that to
demolish The Mill Hall and build a state
of the art smaller Community Hall in its
place was a no-brainer and I was
wondering if that was still the opinion
or whether that had changed obviously
I'd like to see investment going into
the Mill Hall and other community assets
and Heritage cultural assets such as
castle castle Hall
and Council across you never miss an
opportunity to try and divert um but I
will go back to councilor Belton and
actually ask councilor Ward if he wishes
to chip in with an answer because I
think it's important that we are totally
open and transparent about these things
so thank you councilor Belton you have a
first go and Council award if you want
to come in
thank you
um as I said years two and three haven't
been determined yet but absolutely the
assets of the council will all be
considered not just those ones in
Rayleigh but The Freight House Cherry
Orchard we have a vast um array of
assets across the district and we'll be
looking at opportunities to see what can
be improved and where
um I'll let counselor Wall come back on
the other question but I believe you you
know the answer to that already but um
thanks very much
thank you Jim
um well as you can see the Mill Hall is
open
their bookings being taken and it's
ongoing obviously we will be looking to
see what can be done going forward to
see what can be done and we're doing
that at this moment so I can't tell you
any specifics but I can tell you that we
are looking what can be done
thank you Council award Council across
thank you very much can I ask one more
question sorry Council across you get
one supplementary and we have to be
quite strict on these things in the
interest of other questionnaires as well
thank you
foreign
do you want to
read out your question I think to
address to the portfolio holder for
finance economy and climate
um councilor Mrs Belton go ahead Council
of Hoy okay thank you chairman
um to councilor
this is Belton
um to deliver the 2022-23 UK SPF
projects the council we need to
commission third party Consultants or
service providers
considering that the council spent
around 30 percent of the leveling up
fund on Consultants to produce a generic
report can it be guaranteed that
considerably less will be spent on
consultants and reports with this fund
and the monies will be actually spent on
the ground directly benefiting the
district
thank you councilor Hoy council Mrs
Belton
thank you Council Ahoy
um yes we we can guarantee that I'm I'm
certain that we are not going to be
spending considerable sums of this
Budget on consult on consultants over
the past number of years a considerable
amount of money has been spent on
Consultants as you pointed out this has
included surveys and reports all of
which have yielded important information
that has and will continue to help shape
decisions for the district
the council intends to prioritize the
use of this funding towards projects
that are visible within the community
this will improve this may include
physical improvements events exhibitions
activities a significant proportion of
these projects are likely to be
identified in the following two
Financial years as I mentioned earlier
and this could be through a grant
program where third parties would be
able to bid for money to such projects
in combination with Services directly
procured by the council where the
council does use Consultants it intends
that these would only be to facilitate
the delivery of tangible projects such
as those just described
thank you you answered my supplementary
question within that answer thank you
right councilor Hoy uh I want to make a
point in relation to your question I
really welcome your question
um because if you knew the robust
conversations that executive members
have had collectively and individually
with the corporate leadership team about
exactly the point
um but those conversations don't get
recorded publicly so I'm delighted to
have the opportunity tonight to endorse
exactly what councilor Belton has said
and we really have got our eye on that
because there seems to be a good career
to be made by certain Consultants that
go around local authorities
um making an awful lot of money on copy
and paste reports but replacing the name
so I really appreciate that question I
think that's really helpful thank you
very much Council no that's no problem
we um we are trying to positive space a
bit more in these meetings so hopefully
we'll have some more questions in the
future absolutely great to help you as
well thank you
um still here I think we turn to 1.4 to
your question there yes thank you
um again to
uh councilor Mrs Belton
paragraph 3.13 gives a table of where
money is budgeted to be spent E1 shows
300 000 pounds for improvements to town
centers and tire streets historically
spending on these areas have been
restricted to Rochford Rainey and
Hockley
can you guarantee that money from this
budget will be available to the smaller
centers such as whole bridge and great
wakering
interventions the council will seek to
look at locations throughout the
district and whilst we've got a fairly
limited time in this financial year
applications to any future Grant
programs from locations such as whole
Bridge Great White Queen any of the
other villages will be welcomed subject
to meeting any wider eligibility
criteria and we will be encouraging
those parishes and Community groups from
those areas to engage and come forward
with their ideas as they will know those
areas best the council will also
consider proportionately funding
projects in these locations directly
it's likely there will be some degree of
prioritation towards the larger areas
due to
um making the biggest impact to the most
residents but absolutely we want to
engage all residents and groups across
the district and and improve on a wide
variety of areas more details on the
process for identifying projects in year
two and three where the real budget
starts to come forward will be
forthcoming at a meeting of the exec
thank you councilor Belton Council thank
you for that answer that was um
obviously what I wanted to hear as well
I'm sure councilor FD as well I wanted
to hear that with great workering in
mind
um
will I understand that you'll be
Consulting the parish councils and and
Community groups how will you engage
with all the counselors on that or how
will you allow War councilors to be
engaged
so referring back to I think my first
answer to the first question
we want ideas from all members to come
forward
um some ideas won't be relative just to
one Parish they'll be transferable we
don't want to reinvent the wheel we
don't want to duplicate resources so we
want to work together with parishes with
World counselors potentially with County
councilors and look at exactly what we
can do to maximize not only the funding
that we have but the opportunities we
have to benefit the most people
right thank you and in the executive
briefing earlier this week I made
exactly that point that I want all
councilors to be engaged with this sort
of stuff you know officers to be well
aware of all Ward councilors and again I
really welcome uh I don't think it's a
total loving but
um you know I really welcome that
question because it's a point that we've
made consistently that there are a
number of sub-centers around the
Rochford District that must receive
their share of funding and councilor FD
and you've singled him out uh always
makes a plea for great wakering in
particular but also the parades of Shops
and and and areas so again really
welcome your question thank you very
much indeed
um
right if we move on to item number six
on the agenda matters referred to the
executive and reports from other
committees
um I'm not aware that there are any
so that takes us
um quite nicely onto item seven
which is
um
the UK shared Prosperity fund
2022-23 the allegation
um I think if I can turn to you council
Mrs Belton I think you're going to lead
us through this one thank you
thank you and the questions on notice of
quite ably already gone through the
report for me which is which is helpful
so I'll just say a few lines and keep it
um brief so the reports um as a report
States RDC have successfully secured one
million of shared Prosperity funding
following the application of our
investment plan at this time there's one
recommendation as indicated at Point 1.1
and the funding equals 74 450 that we
need to spend this financial year broken
down into the three categories as
displayed in the table at 3.13
given the very short space of time to
deliver this spend and the fact that we
do not know if it can be rolled over and
not through one of asking and I might
add
um we'd like to look at delivering
projects that the council can actually
procure and deliver themselves as I've
already um stated the this evening this
could be things such as deep cleans
Commission of art for the coronation
Heritage projects climate conference to
name a few suggestions that have come
forward so far and I trust everybody's
read the report I'm happy to answer any
questions and I don't think there's much
more to say thank you very much members
any questions that you have on that
particular report
I have one which released 3.24
um and it really
my question really is is there any plan
to set up any any sort of working group
in bringing this back we talk about
being bought back in uh future meetings
but um
is it going to be wider engagement
yeah yeah I mean absolutely going back
to my earlier points about wanting
member engagement I think it's important
I'm not sure if we've already got a
vehicle for delivering a working group
for this and Phil's not into his to my
right but if there isn't I'd certainly
support one being set up because we're
gonna we've done something similar I
believe we've welcomed back where we
engage the parishes and set up meetings
we're going to want to roll that out and
and have something
substance that everybody can feed into
in a timely fashion yeah I mean what I
had in mind really and it comes back to
my answer to councilor Hoy I just want
to see
um member engagement whether or not
that's done by Regional area within
Rochford or whether or not it's done
focused with with Ward members certainly
if there's a specific issue relating to
a part to a particular parade and that
falls within award but certainly I want
to see a much greater linkage to to
members in this work to make sure the
whole of Rochford gets its fair share
which as you say links into Council
always earlier question yeah so I think
so the local partnership group that was
set up when we were putting together the
investment plan
um at 3.18 it sort of lists some of the
people that were engaged we can
certainly make sure that Ward councilors
are invited to the relevant meetings and
as I said I don't think a lot of this
will be World specific I think we need
to make it more broader than that um but
yeah engagement's going to be key to get
the best results
good okay all right
um so Council Ward
if I just come in
um the criteria it's just to ensure that
when it does go out to the various
groups that they understand the criteria
so they are not upset if they are not
able to do something because it doesn't
fill the criteria can we make sure that
that criteria is really out there so
they understand thank you
absolutely and what I would say is this
is exactly why year one funding because
of the short space of time and the the
amount of uncertainty around some of the
criteria because dluck just haven't
provided it yet it needs to be delivered
in-house by the council once that
information has come forward a a clear
eligibility criteria if we go down the
grant row or whatever is decided can be
set out because what we don't want is
there was problems with the welcome back
we all know that where things were put
forward a lot of work went in and it
wasn't able to be delivered for one
reason or another this needs to be more
streamlined but we learned lessons we've
got the Consultants report and we don't
need to go through that again
thank you very much no other points
right
um okay well we turn to the decision
being recommended at 1.1 and I'll read
that out that Authority be delegated to
the Strategic director and director of
place in consultation with the portfolio
holder for finance climate and economy
to allocate and spend funding for
2022-23 in accordance with the council's
approved UK SPF investment plan
members he's had agreed
thank you very much indeed
right we turn to item number eight it
seems to have been the councilor Mrs
Belton Road Show so far so we'll take
the um we take the pressure off a view
and we will turn to item eight I can
sort out my papers
this is the lease a part of Fairview
Pavilion and fenced open area
Fairview playing field Victoria Road
Rayleigh if I can ask you Council Awards
to introduce a report certainly thank
you very much chairman this particular
Pavilion Fairview has been in operation
since 2018
and trudge the people who have been
leasing it have been a very tried and
trusted lessee so we saw no problem in
carrying on the work they were doing and
we were more than happy to agree to this
new lease thank you Jim
thank you Council award any questions of
Council of all Council sparing
thank you chairman I have absolutely no
problem with this this one and and
perhaps I'm diverting a little bit but I
am aware of a number of other Pavilions
that are looking to become part of this
sort of project and Maya just suggest
that we fully engage with local Ward
councilors at that time as when these
things start so that everybody is aware
of what's going on thank you chairman
thank you councilor sparing council Mrs
Rowe
thank you chairman
thank you chairman um
I just want to make sure that we make
sure that the tenants
um actually
carry out the internal maintenance and
that we keep a close eye on that because
obviously we've been criticized in the
past for
issues like that so please can we make
sure that that happens I know they do
keep it clean
um and I support Dave spearing on this
uh Council sparing on this
um they are good tenants
um so let's keep them but if they can
just if we can just keep an eye on the
mountains that'd be great thank you
councilor Ward thank you very much
indeed chairman yeah as as we go to look
at all the other pavilias that we have
which is whole Bridge we will be
speaking with the wall councilors there
and a great wakering with the world
councilors there on those two Pavilions
and their thoughts and ideas in regards
to that and of course all The Pavilions
will have to be monitored regularly to
ensure that the lessee keeps up with the
various contracts that they have signed
thank you Jim
thank you Council award any further
questions or points
okay in that case return to the decision
being recommended and that's at 1.1 and
1.2 first one 1.1 to sign a new lease
for the council owned asset part of the
sports Pavilion and open area located at
Fairview playing field Victoria Road
Rayleigh edged red on the map annexed
here too has appendix one to trudge
Fitness limited as gymnasium and fitness
center use is that agreed members
really
thank you
and to delegate authority to the
director assets and investment in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for strategic planning and assets to
finalize the terms of the lease with
trudge Fitness limited again is that
agreed agreed unanimous thank you
and finally to item nine
cost of living update and in that
respect I turn to councilor Arthur
Williams to update Us in respect of that
report Council Williams
yeah thank you chairman
um the decision we've been is being
recommended is for members to receive an
update of the cost of living
responsive work and the cost of living
working group
um we'll have a couple of other points
I'd like to bring to members attention I
have circulated a report that we've got
together in the last couple of days it's
very difficult to get the data together
at the moment and it is it's an ongoing
situation but um
up to up to now we have had um
we've started off with the warm hubs
been very very successful and we have
Holy Trinity Church Riley hawkwell and
Hockley Methodist Church Rochford Parish
Council Mega Center Rayleigh Bremerton
Community Church holbridge Free Church
Hawker Parish Church day Center the
Rayleigh Methodist Church which has
taken advantage of our funding
um I've actually attended a couple of
them and they are really really
interesting and I have to say that
they're you know
quite entertaining
um we have recently been asked to to
start up a winter pressure Hub this is
um an initiative to help the NHS help
patients out of Hospital we've been
given 46 000 pounds to spend
um on assisting them with this that was
due to go live last Friday in actual
fact it won't be until this Friday or
Monday
um I'll keep you updated on that in in
the report that I have an over issue
tonight there is quite a few pieces of
data which maybe have helped to members
and I will distribute this among all
members as soon as possible
I hope that helps thank you thank you
councilor Williams Council award
thank you chairman uh will this be on
the website as because this is a public
meeting will this also be available to
the public or not
there is nothing here that should be PNC
it's all just straightforward
information yes it will go on the
website thank you very much indeed
council Mrs Bolton
thank you um just one question you just
mentioned um some funding that's been
made available to us to help people back
into their homes is you may not know
this because it's only new but is there
a referral system for counselors to
refer people or is it via the NHS this
is the tricky one so you have to give me
the tricky one right this is totally by
the NHS okay it's not something that we
can do it's to help people as they are
discharged and to see if they need any
help all sorts of things like uh taking
over what the mega said to do during the
pandemic getting medicine getting food
things like that needs to help that
so it's a revs are doing it this year
um for that and also the mega centers
involved it's absolutely it really is
hugely successful what we've done
okay thank you councilor Williams any
further points
no okay
um look this is a good piece of work
um you know it came together
um it's formal documentation about
September October time uh I've been
talking about the need for this Council
to lead the way
um with making sure that it uh you know
came up with a sign posting document
support for residents both where we can
divert we have said on many occasions
that unfortunately much as we might like
we don't have a pot of money that we can
just Dole out and solve everyone's
issues but what we can do is make sure
that we support our community by raising
awareness of the bodies out there that
can give tangible support and we can
also support our own residents who fall
into difficulty or hardship as a result
of the impact of cost of living what I
have asked for and delivered is
the emphasis being shifted from the
signposting which is in place now
obviously added to an enhanced but also
the performance in terms of what we've
achieved and I really appreciate that um
that report which have not had a chance
to read because I've only received it a
few minutes ago but uh Council Williams
you want to come back yeah just one
thing I'd like to point out
um I'd like to thank the officers um
Tracy Lilly and Kelly Redmond for
getting all this information together
and doing what they've done and I'm not
sure if members are aware but um there
was a recent conference on
um uh on the cost of living and Tracy
was asked to to to speak to them from
the experience that we've had especially
with our um the very successful ask the
leader that we we transmitted
um and I have to say it's been really
good once again Rochford leads the back
I feel absolutely right thank you very
much for making that point I heard the
other day that uh Tracy Lilly was
speaking at a conference to highlight
what Rochford what Brent would have done
and Isn't it nice to be up there as
being leading examples and thank you
councilor Williams for your leadership
in this because these things don't just
happen
um you know we'll work together as a
team but you've certainly taken the the
lead in that respect
um and it's a critical issue which is
still with us
um and we're playing our our part to
assist residents as best we're able
thank you if I turn to the decision
being recommended for members to receive
an update on the cost of living response
and work of the cost of living working
group and I think that it's an update
it's really for noting but at 1.1 is
that agreed
thank you members and just before I
close the meeting
um I should have mentioned a little
earlier that I only became aware earlier
this week that our bid to the on the UK
shared Prosperity fund
um that bid actually hadn't been
publicly circulated and I believe I'm
writing saying and I'm looking to Steve
Summers I believe that has now been
rectified hasn't it the um
it's going to go on the website a bit of
an oversight it was no intention not to
actually share that that bid process
um so um that is due to go on the
website
um so there we are right at that point
at
801 802 pm on my watch I'll close the
meeting thank you very much indeed thank
you